[Music]
and now we have got
kelly in charlotte north carolina hey
kelly how's it going
i'm good how are y'all good how can john
and i help today
um i lost my husband about six months
ago after a
four-year long hard battle with cancer
oh i'm so sorry
i'm sorry um well the well the life
insurance money was enough to get out of
debt and
pay the house off and stuff i'm just
having trouble
getting excited about it just given
everything going on
yeah um and you know now the income as
well he was a breadwinner for the most
part so now our income has been slashed
two-thirds so even uh
you know live and give like no one else
is not
what it what we envisioned it to be
and um i was the dave ramsey one for
quite a while in our marriage up until
about the last two years of his life
and then he kind of got on board and we
got to pay off his truck he got really
excited about it
and then um he you know the cancer came
back full force so
i'm just wondering how to go about
re reshuffling my mind to kind of
grab hold of this and to
get excited when it's been such a long
hard goal of mine for a long time yeah
first and foremost i'm i'm so sorry
sounds like this guy was
he's incredible huh he was
truly he paid off his truck in
the middle of fighting for his life
and he cheered it on right yep what a
stunt
you're dead and y'all got little ones
too uh we have a 19 and 22 year old so
not so little i'm the rent of the family
now
they're still little they're still
little um
so
okay i'm just gonna talk blunt with you
is that okay
yes sir okay um you're not gonna get
excited about this
okay there's no there's no your debt
free screen will be very very different
the cheer will be very very different
because you're gonna be doing it alone
and this was something y'all set out to
do together this was
a co-adventure for y'all's family tree
and um man he got you all the way down
the finish line handed that baton off
and you cross the finish line by
yourself right
and so yeah um it's not going to be that
cheer it's not going to be that
excitement
now you can come down to nashville and
do your debt-free screen we will cheer
and scream with you and it'll be a
moment of joy and jubilation but it's
going to look
different and it's going to feel
different okay so
i don't want you to spend another second
of energy
trying to muster up some kind of fake
confetti in your heart that's not there
this was supposed to be the two of you
and it's just you and that's
heartbreaking and it's sad and that's
what grief is right
um there is the reality that you've got
this money
and you've got these bills right is this
house a house that you want to stay in
um for the time being i have a son in
college so i want to stay there at least
until he graduates in three years okay
is there a big
rush to pay it all off or is that
something you just want to do for your
own security
um the rush is just in the fact that i'm
now
um my income has taken such a hit
so the monthly mortgage payment is not
in the budget you know
the 25 and all that sure
so um at some point you might
you know you're six months in is for all
intents and purposes this is still just
as brand new and as real as it was
four months ago five months ago right so
there's a level of healing
and healing does doesn't mean you're not
going to hurt and healing doesn't mean
that you're not going to miss this guy
every single day especially a guy as
awesome as this healing means you're
going to be able to talk about it
and your eyes won't well up on you right
healing means you're going to smile when
you think about the good stuff
right and that's still months and months
months ahead
um if paying off the house and getting
out of debt and clearing that up with
that money and you're able to take care
of college stuff if you're able to do
those things it's going to buy you a
year or two of financial piece so that
you can
then begin to think what i want to do
with my career what i want to do for the
back half of my life how old are you
i'm 54. 54. yeah you're you're just
halfway done yourself right so you got
all kind of adventures ahead of you
it will give you some space and some
time to think through it if you're gonna
sell this house in six months then i
would tell you don't pay it off hang on
to it right get out of your consumer
debt and hang on to the mortgage
um and take a withdraw and pay it off
that way but if you're gonna stay there
for three years four years five years
then yeah pay it off and get some people
that you love and you care around you
and you all celebrate this with a prayer
you'll celebrate this with a
some hugs and some tears but it will
look very very different and then when
you're ready we're going to have a spot
for you here in nashville so you can
come to your debt free scream on our
stage yeah and kelly the only thing that
i would i would add
because i just i love how john
highlighted that it's not going to be
exciting
i would just i would just encourage you
and just affirm
take the pressure off that it should be
um it doesn't have to be
it doesn't have to be exciting this
money represents something you never
wanted to happen
and um and you can still move forward
and use it how you
and he wanted to use it but take the
pressure off
that you should feel a certain way act a
certain way
experience this a certain way i just i
love how john
highlighted that that that is um that is
perfectly okay for you to give yourself
what you need in this season to grieve
and to move forward
one step at a time and we'll be thinking
about you kelly thank you for calling in
john i have you seen um
people experience when they're going
through a season i know you've worked
with a lot of people in
different types of trauma and heartbreak
where they feel a pressure to experience
it a certain way
or to act a certain way or respond a
certain way and kind of wrestling
through that yeah
everybody thinks that they know how they
would react when there's a car wreck or
there's a thing or if what would happen
if
in the realities you don't know and
that's why it's so important to have
people around you
because you think you've got i'm going
to do it like you don't have any idea
you know what i mean so um that's why
it's important that people
bring food and that's why it's important
that we'll have people that will
spend the night with you sleep on your
couch and make sure your pets are eating
and your kids are eating stuff so
um but over six months seven months ten
months so
everybody does this differently cancer
is different than car wrecks and car
wrecks are different than
you know sudden you know milden
everything's different
um you begin to
think what's my new picture going to
look like right what's tomorrow going to
look like i get to craft this and create
it and i didn't plan on it but this is
the way this is and
friends and community members and a good
church member or
a counselor can walk you through what's
it like to dream again cause i've only
dreamed with
this other person right what's this new
thing gonna look like and
don't move and be my grandkids or do i
want to start a new job all those things
look
different and they feel different what
we don't often think christie is that
those are things we practice
right and they are the things you
practice and stumble around into and
that's what again
that's what people are so important for
yeah and i love how um
you know i've hosted with um dave ramsey
before and he always talks about not
making any
major financial decision if you can help
it
so you know yeah six months to a year
after the event because
you can't think clearly you know even if
it costs you a little bit more
in interest or something just give
yourself the space to grieve
to be present to give yourself what you
need and um
and to to be able to think clearly again
once the fog clears a little bit doesn't
mean it's going to be easy
and it doesn't mean you're ever going to
necessarily be excited about it either
let me say this
blessings to this family for having a
will and having life insurance i've sat
with people christy who look at me and
say
we got nothing i don't know what to do
now like they're going to have to grieve
at work on monday because they don't
have any money
good for him if you don't have a will
get
a will get a will and take care of your
family after you're gone
it is a selfless thing you can do it's
not fun to talk about but you'll be so
glad everyone will be so glad you did
thanks for the call kelly